now welcome to Playstation grenades for
tonight Season eight has been with us a
few weeks now
long enough for players to have settled
into their landing boutiques this means
we can highlight locations you can
utilize for relatively safe starts and
hopefully something easy wins all
locations are times dumped in the
description below and of course my
super-secret loot run is the last one on
the list in the hopes that you'll stay
longer if you have a great landing spot
you dare share or just want to chat give
me a shout on twitter i'm adam arrow or
adam grenade over there fYI these drops
are tactical drops to give you the edge
in battle which will also give you good
loot the ability to scout your enemy
safely and the potential of great
rotations to pick and choose your
battles as the storm closes in i'm
talking too much again sorry I'll shut
up let's crack on right the first one
will sound absolutely ridiculous but but
bear with me please the potential for
dropping at the Block during season 8 is
a really good idea I don't know about
you but I've never dropped there before
this season because it's an unknown
entity well in season 8 the block has a
guaranteed tier 6 chest if you play save
the world you'll be suitably impressed
there but if you don't this means a
guaranteed God weapon can be found in a
chest at the block and of course it
comes with a healing item too as I'm
writing this the block is this sort of
turtle think metal works here's what you
can do first find the location of the
epic chest in playgrounds and figure out
the best way to drop there to get it
first from here
it's your choice play aggressive or sit
back and take out the inevitable other
player who's trying to find that chest
it isn't all plain sailing because sadly
that golden weapon can be trash like a
scoped hand cannon or one of those night
vision rifles so you'll need to decide
if the risk is worth it so to reiterate
use playground to learn the chest spawn
points jump into game and take the block
as your own another good point about the
block are the above-average chests and
ammo box bonds in general visiting here
mid game can also help replenish your
squads ammo stars I suppose what I'm
saying is the
should no longer be ignored give it a
try I'd love to know your thoughts after
taking the block be aware that there is
a vending machine right outside for
another free weapon definitely worth a
visit in terms of rotation the next step
is to either go up to the outpost above
pleasant Park and grab a bloody hamster
ball or use the rift by the derp burger
simples did I just say simples what a
sub with all the attention on the new
areas of the map there's a season 5 loot
run which is zero stress its relaxing
and leaves you well placed to attack
others here's the run when dropping from
the bus look for this rock formation
which can house two chests take the
stone while you're here next venture
into the junkyard which has another five
chests and usually nobody around
depending at which point in the season
you visit this there is a pirate convoy
going past on the road which has three
more chests which bring the total up to
ten already should that convoy of green
and gone move around to the right and
you'll see more rock formations which
are great to get your stone stars up to
500 and of course even more chests too
if you're lucky walking off towards the
farm and you'll see a chest by the
winnebago and two more potentially in
the farmhouse
keep heading north to the wooden shack
and yet another chest on a perfect day
you can open 16 chests without another
person in sight not a bad afternoons
work and because this run ends just
outside Paradise Palms it's really easy
to third party group fighting or just
take advantage of the last person left
alive
a few seasons ago we looked at Dakota's
landing spot which was by the two
incomplete bridges back then it was
great because it had rifts nearby to
rotate anywhere that was ain't here
anymore but we have the next best thing
let's drop in and have a look the bridge
on the east side is now a pirate base
with four chests in very close proximity
there's also another one underneath the
main structure and if you want on the
opposite side of the bridge is another
chests of six as a starting point not
bad in each of the pirate forts are a
lot of material many people miss or
ignore if you see these bags of pirate
gold give them a smack as they offer
some damn good metal resources here's
the next part of the plan look for the
cannon aiming toward polar peak jump in
and hopefully if you fire yourself in
the right direction you'll land near
these two broken houses with lots of
floor loot and two more chests quickly
grab what you can but look we have
another mode of transport here the
geezers the guys's the key however you
say it those water things in the floor
pop on this and travel towards retail
row you should fall short and land by
these two newly renovated houses with
four more chests to plunder at the end
of the run you'll have the drop on
anyone venturing out of retail row and
about twelve chests opened in two
minutes not bad not bad at all
[Music]
season 8 introduced pirate themed caches
to find around the map I find the two
main areas to find maps with a new area
in the top right hand corner around the
volcano but also on the opposite side of
the map particularly around haunted
hills I have a fantastic little loop run
which doesn't look very impressive when
you see it but it does give you the
highest chance of a treasure map drop so
let's give it a crack start this run by
landing on the new rabbit structure
which can house two chests for immediate
loot drop down to the house nearby
and get another chest in the roof and
hopefully a treasure map from here start
heading north but grab a few mushrooms
for your troubles on your way here you
should find two underused houses with
more chests to plunder 5 if we're
looking from here I recommend going into
Haunted Hills for a few reasons mainly
is because there's usually a fight here
and you can third party both people
pretty safely or better still there is
someone here trying to find the X or a
treasure map they picked up taking
somebody else's treasure map it's just
as good as finding your own do we agree
good this run doesn't yield enough
chests in a squad game but first all our
match
8 chests before surprising your first
victim should be relaxing enough now
feels like a great time to immortalize
some legends these guys use my code and
amaru in the fort night shop I've been
absolutely blown away by the support
recently I've never had so many people
to thank so once again I really
appreciate it you're all legends to me
if I missed anyone please get in touch
via twitter i'm adam grenade over there
and i'm looking for people to talk to so
come over say hello at some point anyway
let's get back to this
there's a super-secret native village
with tents and a llama skeleton to find
hidden in the forests above sunny
steppes it's so well hidden
it's the perfect starting point for a
solo game each of these little Hut's has
the potential of either a chest or ammo
crate three chests maximum plus the
materials here are plentiful and the
chances of Benton a coupon are so slim
dare I say it you can relax from here
there are loads of zip wires to get
around on but I'm using those for the
next run so instead venture into the
unnamed outpost southwest for six more
chests high-quality ground loot and so
many freaking ammo crates it's unheard
of this outpost has all the mobility you
need making it a great starting point in
its own right but I tend to see a couple
of people dropping here every time by
using the native village you can kit up
and decide when you want to fight rather
than being pushed at a point that
doesn't suit you and come on this llama
skeleton is so lucky if you destroy it
you will 100% win the game I guarantee
it
okay it's time the Beast loop run of
season eight to start this one we are
looking for an ex off to the right of
the volcano and off of lonely launch x
marks the spot here's where our run
begins firstly there could be two chests
just waiting here at the starting point
your next move is to go north to the
outpost which holds a further three
chests and potentially a vending machine
which is definitely worth a look
also note the amount of travel options
should you need them next keep heading
north to the zip wire look down and
you'll see a small pyramid hidden by the
trees potentially two more chests in
there continuing north there's a chance
of a naturally spawning treasure map
just here but if not keep heading north
there's a chest inside this structure
and another north by the makeshift
campsite bringing our total up to seven
so far the next zip wire takes us to
another outpost and chest
now we're heading west for another
campsite and another structure with yet
more chests now we are up to 11 chests
by the way and traveling west towards
the solar power station for three more
chests you are likely reaching
civilization now and other players will
probably be around so you need to choose
wisely
do you want to keep using the zipline to
loot and move for another four chests
that lazy Lagoon and a couple more
beyond that or you could try venturing
into the outpost directly south for six
chests but far higher chances are
fighting here if you get every single
chest on this run it's 25 chests in
total but of course feel free to start
it halfway through finish it early do
what you like with this one there is so
much you can do with it this route in
particular should have you in charge of
your own destiny continuously moving and
being able to decide when you want to
attack or not of course we can never
guarantee a win because there's those
sweaty players I'd like to build battle
themselves and on the flip side of that
I make terrible mistakes all the time
like this but I'm getting better slowly
so anyway I do hope that these help
right we did it and the usual point
about these landing locations around the
edge of the map they always give you a
high probability chance of launch pubs
which I always say are great for
late-game rotating into the new circle
before others can result in easy wins
although in this scenario I tried my
best to use my face to stop his sniper
rounds but anyway a wins a win alright
can we move on I'm Martin from
Playstation grenades if you'd like more
for my content please let me know in the
comments I'm using cold atom arrow in
the shop is by far the best thing
I hugely appreciate what Walden anyway
I'll shut up now I'm joystick I'm a
voice I'll see you very soon enjoy the
rest of season eight
[Music]